in each of the following three
expressions find values of the variable
that make the rational expression
undefined then state the domain so let's
think about a little bit how can we get
these rational expressions to be
undefined well the best way I know how
is to get them divided by zero because
if you have anything if you have
anything divided by zero this is
undefined we've never as mathematicians
we've never defined what this equals
literally it is undefined so we need to
think what makes these expressions
undefined and then they want us to state
the domain and the domain sounds like a
very complicated thing but the domain is
really just all of the set of numbers
that we can put into an expression or a
function that make it defined so it'll
essentially be all the numbers except
the things that make it undefined so
let's think about it a little bit let me
clear let me clear this out let me clear
that let's go look at the first one so
what would we have to do what X values
would make this expression undefined
well see X values that would make the
denominator equal to zero and this will
be equal to the denominator equal to
zero when six minus X is equal to zero
if you add X to both sides of this
equation you get six is equal to X or
you get X is equal to six so in the
first problem the value x equals six
makes the rational expression this whole
rational expression it makes it
undefined and if you wanted its domain
you could write the domain of number one
over here the domain here is all real
numbers
all real numbers real numbers except
except except six so you could put any
number into this for X and you will get
a value if you take this as a function
it will be defined other than six if you
put six here you get an undefined value
you get zero over zero that is undefined
not acceptable so you have to leave that
out of the domain the the set of valid
inputs or the inputs for which this
expression is defined let's do the next
one so you have 3y over y squared minus
16 once
and the what the y-values that will make
this undefined are the ones that'll make
the denominator equal zero so the
denominator is y squared minus 16 is
equal to zero or if you add 16 to both
sides you get Y squared is equal to 16
or Y could be the positive or negative
square root of 16 so Y so I'll do it up
here because I need to save space for
this one so I'll so if you take the
square root the positive and negative
square root of this or you could say Y
is equal to plus or minus 4 so either
positive 4 or negative 4 is going to
make the denominator 0 and will result
in an undefined expression so you have
to exclude these or another way of
saying that the domain here for the
second problem or the second expression
right over here or we could view this as
a function definition the domain is all
real numbers all real numbers except
except for and negative for except for
and negative for any other real number
other than 4 and negative 4 you can put
into this expression and get a valid
defined value if you put 4 negative 4
you don't get a defined Hall you get an
undefined value let's do this one so
once again we need to figure out all the
Z values that will make this denominator
equal to 0 because then this expression
this rational expression will be and
when we see rational expression we're
really just saying something has a
numerator and a denominator like this or
is some some expression over another
expression right there there all right
you could kind of view it as a fraction
if you want to view it in more I guess
everyday language but to make this
undefined this business down here has to
be equal to 0
so Z squared plus 5z plus 6 needs to be
equal to 0 and looks like we can factor
this we can find two numbers whose
product is 6 and whose sum is 5 well
that's 2 & 3 so the same thing is Z plus
2 times Z plus 3 you can verify that for
yourself that it really does factor out
like this and so when would this it went
with this denominator equals 0 well if
these if the product of these two
expressions equals 0 that means one or
both of them need to be equal 0 so this
means that either
plus two is equal to zero or Z plus
three equals zero any either of these
would make this entire expression equal
to zero because would turn one of these
parentheses into zero and anything times
a zero is a zero so Z plus two equals
zero subtract two from either side you
get Z is equal to negative two or
subtract three from both sides of this
you get Z is equal to negative three so
if Z is negative two or Z is negative
three this denominator will become zero
even though we're it's equal negative
three you get zero over zero but this
denominator will become zero and the
expression is undefined so the domain
here the domain the domain here is all
real numbers all real numbers except
except negative two and and negative
three these two will make it undefined
any other number you'll get a valid
result and I want to make it clear
because we're going to start simplifying
expressions like this and you might say
okay this expression over here is the
same thing as Z plus three over Z plus 2
times Z plus three and there'll be a
temptation here to say hey look I got a
Z plus three in the numerator I have a Z
plus three in the denominator can't I
just divide the numerator denominator by
Z plus three and have them cancel out
and then you would get 1 over Z plus 2
and you'd say well aren't these the same
expression or if you set them equal to
if you define them as a function you
might say hey aren't these two things
the same function and the answer is they
are not the same function this and this
are different functions and the reason
why is because they have different
domains the way just the way you've
written it right now this one you could
get a Z equals negative three and you
would get a valid answer this one you
couldn't you would get a zero in the
denominator so if you want this to if
you want these to truly be the same
function you have to restrict their
domain so in order for this to be the
same as that you have to have you have
to add the caveat that the domain here
that the domain here is is all real
numbers all real numbers real numbers
except X effed negative two
and negative three or that's defined
only for all real numbers other than
negative two negative three now this if
you constrain the domain is the same
thing as this with this domain right
over here because you now say look
negative three is not defined over here
if you didn't have this constraint
negative three could have been